peace for me is having a sense of inner
joy and being happy about your life to
you and of course you'll have sad days
everybody life is suffering as no one
does not suffer in life and there's lots
of problems but you know beyond our life
life is good and it's especially good
when you deepen your own relationships
around you your family your friends your
community and that stretches out at
night to a wider community but find
those put on your roots with your
relationships relationships that sustain
us all you know we all start in the
peace movement by wanting to change the
world and have lots of important
projects and we come back to the reality
that it's the people around us it's the
relationships that are really important
and I think that helps made life very
enjoyable when you have good
relationships